all right meanwhile elsewhere in the
democrat party um nancy pelosi yesterday
made a somewhat bizarre announcement
earlier in the day when she was at a
press conference and she said that uh oh
by the way a little bit later i'll be
reading a poem
written by bono about putin and
there was never there was never any
other explanation as far as i know it's
like why who
why is bono sending nancy pelosi poems
is there something going on between
those two we need to know about
and uh what's happening exactly none of
that's explained but then a little bit
later nancy pelosi gets up
and this is all documented by c-span she
gets up in front of a you know the the
the select crowd and reads this poem
that bono wrote about putin
hoping that this would cancel world war
iii
let's find out if it was successful
before i introduce them i want to i got
this message
this morning
from bono
and most of us we're always whether
we're in ireland or here or whatever it
is abano has been a very irish part of
our lives
and he said
this
he said oh saint patrick
he drove out the snakes with his prayers
but that's not that's not all it takes
for the smoke symbolizes an evil that
arises and hides in your heart as it
breaks and the evil from risen from
friends from the darkness that lives in
some men but in sorrow and fear that's
when saints can appear
to drive out those old snakes once again
and they struggle for us to be free from
the psycho in this human family
ireland sorrow and pain is now the
ukraine
and saint patrick's name is now zolinsky
[Applause]
well that did it
world war three is canceled the war's
over
from what i understand
putin packed up went took well sent all
the troops home and that was it that was
the end of it
um that poem i mean
first of all nancy pelosi is that was a
there was a terrible i don't know if we
can blame i don't know who to blame
primarily for this do we blame bono or
do you blame nancy plus because there's
a terrible rendition she did an awful
job i mean
bono sent you a poem for some reason and
you're gonna you're gonna recite it on
camera
did you not practice it ahead of time a
little bit
try to do bono some favors here
make it sound a little bit better but so
it's a terrible rendition the poem
itself was was awful
uh and in in in the
in the poem
uh zielenski is now a saint
and he's a saint patrick
specifically
so
between the song we played yesterday for
you and this poem
as as on this show we were just
assaulting your eardrums with the
cringiest material imaginable and it's
going to get worse from here by the way
i got to tell you we got a few more
things to play in a second
and you're going to really hate me by
the end of it um
but between those two things zelinski is
superman
jesus christ
a saint a man who's going to save the
world and saint patrick's st patrick
my god we're just losing our minds
we're losing our minds
now this so so but the real question we
have i think
and i'm sure you thought this when
you're listening to that
which poem was better was it this one
was it bono's poem for putin
or was it the whatever that cw actress
who wrote the poem for putin about how
if she was putin's mother and if you
don't remember that poem
then
let's listen to it again
dear president vladimir putin
i'm so sorry that i was not your
mother if i was your mother you would
have been so loved
held in the arms of joyous light
never would the stories plight the world
unfurled before our eyes a pure demise
of nations sitting peaceful under a
night sky if i was your mother
the world would have been warm
so much laughter and joy and nothing
would harm i can't imagine the stain the
soul-stealing pain that the little boy
you must have seen and believed
formulation of thought quickly i can't
do it i can't do it
that one's worse that one's still that
one is still worse i mean
listen that's that's an achievement in
its own right it's hard to out cringe
bono
you know bono is kind of like
it is and has been forever cringe made
manifest
the cringe became man and it was bono um
so it's it's hard it's b and given the
the field you're playing on here
cringy poetry that's bono's deal that's
what he does
and
somehow that chick was able to outdo him
so you gotta some respect there
and we're just going to gloss right over
the fact that pelosi said that bono is a
very irish part of our lives what
what does that
mean
this is what happens when we have a
bunch of 97 year olds running
the world at a moment like this
[Music]